*screeching*
(jumps out of closet again)
Hey Vsauce, Michael here
*LWIAY intro*
Welcome to LWIAY (original idea)
Before this video begins, I don't know if I told you guys about my chair, only 399!
I don't know - also if you're aware of this, but it can do thi-
Oh wow!
Shamelessly plugging your meme merch Felix
Wow, wow, round of applause for me everybody
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Yes, I do want to pay for an outdated meme Felix
Thank you finally for answering us
Hey listen up, you slimy scumbag
This orange sh-sh-shirt is fire
Literally it is - it is so tight man
Oh boy
Hey look at that face, huh?
Can you do that face?
We spent hours perfecting this art.
Okay. We spent years. That's why it took so long
"Aye Felix..
I'm gonna get bullied if anyone sees me wearing that"
Oh yeah, but can you do?
*abrupt pause*
This?
*explosion boi*
Enough, enough plugging your merch Felix
Who are you? Logan Paul?
Let's review the memes from last week we had some amazing stuff
I've - I've been sneak peeking a little bit
Very very quality hey, can I copy your homework?
That's my Irish accent by the way sure just change a few things so it's not obvious
Okay top foot up on into you. I did a little meme here that Jack were the exact same attire
For his TV presentation, you know I'm proud
I'm proud of my my boy
But uh you straight up stole my outfit Jack and you know it
So I light handedly try and hand this to him, but of course jack has to make a comment about my handshake
Disability, and I gotta tell you I'm really disappointed in Jack me and the handshake disability community are strong
Okay, and we're stronger than you and your hatred so next time you make fun of anyone for
Not being a mistakes
Maybe you should think
Do you smoke every time I die in a video game your lungs are in perfect health of course they are
This meme was made by cyranek , he's got an amazing channel you guys should check it out.
I've seen this one great job reposting
Okay, and then the final stage can be the shirt
the most valuable photo company sells no cameras
the largest network lays no cables
the largest accommodator provider owns
No real estate the largest and most subscribed youtube channel creates no content on own
*sad music*
They figured me out seven things they finally learned my secret
god damn it the hell is this oh
Hell yeah
Miss me with that price 399, baby. It just keeps going my god
Hey
Hey come come on
come come
That that was f**king great I gotta upvote that.
Derp Chris. Well done. What is this upload so Pewdiepie can see this?
Oh ma god that's so- hey! damn it...
Oh yeah?
Yeah, gotcha
Hey guys don't make fun of
The Minecraft Pig okay? He has feelings too. Please.
Narrator: A part of you or worst..
*screams*
That's great. Sir you've been in a coma since 2000
It's 2018 now what games do gamers play now?
Sudoku. That's right guys anyone can be a gamer you can just play
Sudoku on your phone and you can still be an epic gamer dude just like myself
$398??
never been this angry in my life
It's a great deal.
It's a great deal guys!
If we can sell at least 50 more,
then I get more royalty please.
Got today's video it was only
Seven minutes, so what did you do about it? I didn't do anything whoa well Brad Brad knows
He knows that there will be consequences if the video doesn't hit ten minutes that
He doesn't even want to get into that he would even dare to get into
touch
This is Brad and this is supposed to be my our site got another video see I mentioned Cyprus well
You're welcome son. Got another video to edit should be easy it's from PewDiePie. Let's see
It's five minutes long come on you can you can easily please..
stretch that out. Come on.
What's with the ten minutes means? Come on!
Makes actual good content worth ten minutes puts in
intros and outros to
Puts in intros and outros to well if you gotta make a meme at least
Fuckin hell
put in intros and outros to extend the video to 10 minutes calls out other youtubers to make a 10 minute video
Coughs after every 10 excuse me
(Come on he was sick. JK :D)
Seconds to make
check mate Flat Earth-ers. Wow.. another solid evidence for the Flat Earth community
Your move Neil
the b***h Tyson.
I made this at school. Hope you will you like it.
Oh my god, and I'm wearing the shirt. Hell yeah!
I like how he gave me the pug eyes that are almost like popping out
That's amazing, those eyes can see the future. My dad in Vietnam
1971 didn't know this photo existed until I came across randomly on the internet. He cried when he saw it.
Hope this is the right place to post
(In beastmaster64's voice)
Beastmaster 64, I haven't seen that son-of-a-bitch face in years.
everyone is like "can you bring back Beastmaster?"
Yeah, I'll bring back Beastmaster when Pokemon Go is popular again. What do you what do you think I'm gonna?
What in the world am I looking at? How youtubers gets their ideas is asked question and
Answers them ask questions and fans answered them waits for JacksFilms to upload
It's not true he copied me everyone knows that
Moving on, this drawing has taken 84 years. I hope you like it. I absolutely love it
It is 10 out of 10. I just traced a screen from a video, stop upvoting this.
I think the the awfulness of it actually makes it look good so props to you
Burger King foot lettuce.
Like if you cried guys, please like if we cried it on this video and buy the merch if you didn't
Remember the booger boy from Zelda .
This is him now, feel old yet?
Awh man..
That's it normally. We just edit that out
But I know but I know my editors are so wonderful and nice that they will make me look as good as possible
Any scenario and if something disgusting happens that I don't want to be shown. They would do the
They would do me justice and cut it out. Hah..
Ah that's sick
wait
Wait for him to jump out of the closet. You merely adopted the closet
I was born in the closet clearly only Marzia knows how to model a hat
Why do you have to bully me all the time? Find enough videos to make a You Laugh You Lose long enaugh
repeat the same video at least three times
What?
What are you talking about?
Listen, do you know how hard it is to find videos that aren't copyrighted that won't claim my video after a week
I lose all revenue, do you know my pain? Do you know my suffering? Then now
I will repeat the video three times four times if necessary
Mini crossbow shooting targets how do we know you're not a giant?
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm... mmm! (moving on)
What is this. Oh my-
Argh da pain!
Stop compiling my bad handshakes, please! Mom can I hang out with my friends tonight?
Yeah, as long as you bring your brother..
Hope you like it. Please give it up, bub. That's dope I want those glasses when there is no
bonus meme
That's right
Truly the saddest moment of the week is when there is no bonus meme
waiting around the corner. I understand nice chair
I love the background. It's so detailed and well drawn incredible.
It looks it looks photorealistic
Well done. I'm kidding great job sir junkman very nice
Marzia is learning.
10:01
I've never been so proud
I think she even mentioned it to me because she noticed that it was and she was like my video was 10:01
Eating a picture of PewDiePie every day until he eats a picture of me. I'm not gonna eat the picture, just stop.
Ok? it's not happening. Alright leave a like if you enjoyed watching cop that merch, cop that chair.
Do whatever you want. I don't care.
That rhymed?
Squad fam out